A pulmonary embolism is a
blood clot in the veins of the lung.
It is one of the most dangerous
types of venous thromboembolism,
which is the general term for
when blood clots form in veins.
Pulmonary embolism occurs when
a small blood clot or embolus breaks off
from a larger clot or thrombus
and travels to the lung,
where it can cause a potentially
life-threatening blockage.
Symptoms include chest pain, shortness of breath,
heart palpitations, coughing up blood,
fainting, and in severe cases, signs
of shock and low blood pressure.
These symptoms are caused
by damage to the lungs,
which also affects the heart —
the right ventricle in particular.
The right side of the heart pumps blood to the
lungs, and is thinner and weaker than the left.
When a pulmonary embolism
blocks the blood vessels of the lung,
there's a sudden increase in
pressure in the pulmonary artery.
This increases the afterload
of the right ventricle,
which is the pressure the heart
must work against to pump blood.
As a result, in some patients, the
right ventricle has to work harder
to keep pumping blood, but
after a certain threshold it fails.
This disrupts blood flow to vital organs, leading to death — a process known as haemodynamic collapse.
Individuals at increased risk of
pulmonary embolism include older people,
those with pneumonia, those
undergoing surgery and long hospital stays,
people who have major bone fractures with trauma
and people who are immobilised for long periods.
Other medical conditions can also be a risk factor,
such as genetic diseases of the coagulation cascade,
sickle cell disease, and chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease.
There are a number of treatments
available for pulmonary embolism,
including antithrombotic treatment with
drugs such as direct oral anticoagulants
vitamin K antagonists, and low molecular weight heparin.
There are also medical procedures
such as reperfusion therapy
to restore blood flow to the blocked vessels.
Despite these treatments, up to one in ten
patients will die of venous thromboembolism
within one year, and at least one in five patients
will have recurrence within five years
if their venous thromboembolism developed without
a clear cause — so-called idiopathic thromboembolism.
Patients who survive can develop post pulmonary embolism syndrome,
a poorly understood condition
characterised by exercise intolerance,
shortness of breath and
a reduction in quality of life.
As research continues, a better
understanding of pulmonary embolism
and improved treatment should
lead to better chances of survival
and a better quality of life
for those with this condition.